three years after all the powers that be
attacked and censored anyone who
suggested that kovid may be escaped from
a Chinese bio lab called us all crazy
conspiracy theorists more and more
government agencies are admitting that
the virus
most likely came from the Chinese bio
lab but so what the Liberals are simply
claiming that back then the science
suggested that the virus originated in
nature and now they say the science has
developed and shown that it likely began
in the lab no big deal that's how
science is supposed to work right
not quite now that Republicans control
the House of Representatives we are
finally able to investigate and see how
that early scientific consensus
developed and it turns out
it's not very scientific in fact it's
looking
pretty much entirely political
on April 17 2020 here is what Dr fauci
told reporters
there was a study recently where a group
of Highly qualified evolutionary
virologists looked at the sequences in
bats as they evolve and the mutations
that it took to get to the point where
it is now totally consistent with a jump
of a species from an animal to a human
so the paper will be available I don't
have the authors right now but we can
make it available to you
straightforward enough right
sounds like it except what fauci didn't
tell you
is that he was the guy who prompted the
study specifically in order to debunk
the lab League theory that we now know
was almost certainly correct
and that we knew at the time actually
many of us was almost certainly correct
according to the House Republicans and
Democrats investigating fauci this is a
bipartisan Select Committee
quote
the evidence available to the select
subcommittee suggests that Dr Anthony
fauci prompted Dr Christian Anderson
Professor Scripps Research to write
proximal origin
and that the goal was to disprove any
lab League Theory
the select committee
found that Dr Anderson privately did not
find the natural origin Theory
particularly compelling despite saying
so publicly
this is how fake news Works whether
we're talking about fake news in the
Trump Russia hoax whether we're talking
about fake news in my own recent run-in
with being accused of genocide to the
fake news from Dr fauci in the origin of
covid
the liberal operators who control the
scientific media big Tech and government
establishments work in collusion with
one another
so in the case of kovid they concoct the
scientific rationale
which is then adopted by the government
which is then reported on by the media
which is then protected through
censorship of contrary views by big Tech
all to push a conclusion that they had
already reached from the very beginning
a conclusion that was political in
nature then occasionally we find out the
whole thing was a political operation
but only later long after the Revelation
would have had any practical political
effect falsehood flies and truth comes
limping after it in this case well into
Dr fauci's Pleasant retirement
where unfortunately it seems he will
face no consequences for his deceit I'm
Michael Knowles as the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Toby who says
the real reason Michael gave this CPAC
speech was to get Ben to defend him for
the first time did Ben defend me I
haven't caught up on all the shows did
Ben wow
that's how you know that what I said at
CPAC was completely 100 percent there's
no way to attack it is even
Ben is saying I was totally right I love
that I absolutely love that that is some
people have said it would be a chilly
day in hell
when Ben would come out and defend
Yours Truly but when you want to avoid
hell when you want to go to heaven when
you want to be closer to God you got to
check out hello head on over to
hallow.com Knowles lent is already in
full swing giving things up even for a
short time is never easy
something that I will not give up is my
faith I certainly hope and pray I never
give it up with all the uncertainty in
this world there is no better time than
now to start building a daily habit of
prayer and meditation with hallow hallow
is the number one Christian Prayer app
and the number one Catholic app in the
world pray every single day leading up
to Easter with world famous Catholics
and Protestants alike such as Jim
Caviezel father Mike Schmitz and even
Mark Wahlberg dive deep into scripture
and the second most read Christian book
of all time the imitation of Christ you
will learn how to become a better
individual in spite of today's broken
world through prayer fasting and giving
hallow will help guide you on your
journey to become more like Christ
download Hello at hello.com
and get an exclusive three months free
which will carry you through lent and
Easter that is three months absolutely
free at hallow.com Knowles
we are now all basically agreeing that
kovid came from the lab right you know
there was that report from the energy
Department the energy Department saying
now yeah now we think kovid probably
came from that lab we have heard from
the FBI this clip was from a week or two
ago uh Christopher Ray the FBI director
admitting yeah we yeah that's pretty
much that's what we think now there's
this department of energy study that
says it's likely to have come from a lab
leak although the confidence is low it
cites the FBI
what is the determination by the FBI so
as you note Brett the FBI has for quite
some time now assessed that the origins
of the pandemic are most likely a
potential lab incident in Wuhan
yes we do know that we've all known that
for a very long time but only now is
this being accepted by the powers that
be so why is it my question is not
okay how did the virus leak we know how
the virus leaked we're at least pretty
certain of it my question always when
truths that we have long suspected are
finally being mainstreamed
why now why why are they releasing it
now I wonder if the reason that the
government and the media establishment
are willing to release this now is
because tensions with China are a little
bit higher back in those early days I I
think that everyone was a little softer
on China now we've had the Spy balloon
coming across you're seeing more
incursions from China into the South
China Sea there's a little more tension
around a potential Invasion or blockade
of Taiwan Taiwan is economically and
technologically very important for the
United States so is that maybe what's
going on that this is a game of chess
being played by people who did not just
yesterday discover this who actually
from those early days suspected it but
now it's starting to play out you've
always got to ask yourself these
questions when it comes to the news
first question that you've got to look
at is not anything to do with the
details of Any Given news story the
first question is why am I being
presented with this story
why am I being presented with this
headline and why are they doing it right
now
but even just on the operation of fake
news this is how fake news works all the
time they get the story wrong very often
they get the story intentionally wrong
to achieve a political purpose and then
you get the you get the fake news on
page A1 of the newspaper and you get the
retraction or the correction or even
just the stealth edit on page Z 10 000
of the newspaper so very few people see
it everyone sees the original fake
headline very few people see the
correction I did just experience this
very recently when the libs decided to
accuse me of genocide and and quickly
enough they had to change the headlines
because it was obviously libelous
but all the libs not you the
conservatives understood this from day
one every prominent conservative even
the prominent squishy type of
conservatives who don't even like me all
that much they all came out immediately
said this is such a bogus story but the
libs all saw the fake headline how many
of those Libs who are now calling me a
genocidal Maniac how many of them saw
the very quick Corrections that the news
organizations had to make because they
were violating libel law and their
lawyers I'm sure called the editorial
team and said you got to change the
headlines many fewer people so there's
Corrections especially because there
were stealth edits so I mentioned
yesterday on the show that after I
demanded a retraction Daily Beast
Rolling Stones some other outlets pretty
quickly changed their headlines now
Huffington Post has changed their
headlines because they're afraid of
hearing from their own lawyers I think
the independent the UK has changed their
headlines but they didn't want to add
any editorial notes so we pointed out
hey this is still libelous okay so now
they're starting to add editorial notes
acknowledging the change this is my
favorite one this is my favorite
editor's note for a correction that I
have ever seen in my whole life in any
news story and I feel so privileged that
it just happens to be from a story that
involves me editors note
the headline has been changed to more
literally reflect the words nulls used
the headline has been changed from the
complete BS that we lied about the words
that we put into his mouth now okay
we're changing the headline to reflect
what he actually said
it's it's just such an admission you
could say editor's note we are hereby
acknowledging that we The Daily Beast
publish fake news we are a fake news
organization and occasionally we cross
the line into legally actionable libel
so okay we'll use the words he actually
used remember that I want to frame this
editor's note I want this to be on the
wall of my studio
editor's note don't believe anything
that you read in the liberal press
so and it was very kind of every
everyone to come out and defend me all
the people on the right one person in
particular who did that was Senator Mike
Lee who pointed out this is slide less
and the guy knows quite a lot about
constitutional law of being a supreme
court litigator and a U.S senator so
moving on from all the nonsense about
about my CPAC speech Senator Lee just
had a wonderful exchange with a uh a
woman who is from the Independent
Women's Law Center on the topic of sex
and gender but not
specifically on the topic of
transgenderism
he actually dug into an issue that goes
back much further
and it goes a lot deeper
an issue where
if we want to really get at the heart
of our present crazy sexual gender
Madness
which is dominating the headlines is all
the libs want to talk about and
therefore the conservatives have to talk
about it because it's upending society
that issue
is before
transgenderism before redefining
marriage before all the crazy sexual
Revolution stuff it goes all the way
back to feminism and the feminist
would-be Constitutional Amendment called
the era the Equal Rights Amendment which
would destroy women's rights in America
first though when we're talking about
rights the rights that you have in the
workplace even things regarding sexual
harassment you got to check out Bambi
right now go to bambi.com type Michael
Knowles under podcast when you sign up
when you are running your business your
employees can create all kinds of
interesting situations to put it
delicately for instance if an employee
reports a serious issue such as sexual
harassment do you have a documented
policy for how to handle that situation
that's why you better talk to Bambi
Bambi gives you access to your own
dedicated HR manager this person is
available to you by phone email and
real-time chat a person will help you
run employee onboarding terminations and
performance reviews with Bambi's HR
autopilot feature you can automate
important HR practices such as setting
policies employee training and feedback
procedures all of Bambi's HR managers
are based in the US and can support the
nuances across all 50 states HR managers
can easily cost 80 grand per year Bambi
starts at just 99 per month incredible
incredible value you schedule your free
conversation today to see how much Bambi
can take off your plate go to bambi.com
right now type Michael Knowles under
podcast when you sign up that is Bambi
b-a-m-b-e-e.com bambi.com type in
Michael Knowles
Senator Lee has recently dug into
a recurrent an almost perennial leftist
issue it's been cropping up since the
70s it's called the era the Equal Rights
Amendment this is the feminist
Constitutional Amendment that ironically
though not so ironically if you really
understand feminism but seems ironically
would destroy rights for women in
America and the era the libs have been
trying to ratify this thing for decades
now people don't actually want it which
is why I keep stalling out but Senator
Lee asked Jennifer braceres who's at the
Independent Women's Law Center what the
era really would look like in practice
what might this do
for sex-segregated prisons prisons for
women what might this do for
government-sponsored government-funded
and operated uh shelters for uh for
Abused Women for example or public
restrooms locker rooms athletic
facilities athletic competitions what
might strict scrutiny do to every one of
those so in the racial context courts
have been very clear that prisons cannot
separate inmates on the basis of race
even where doing so would prevent
certain gang
violence in the prison and that's that's
the right standard they should not be
able to separate inmates on the basis of
race if you apply that same standard to
men and women that would mean that
prisons could never they would have to
have co-ed prisons you could never
separate inmates on the basis of sex
and male and female prisoners would have
to be housed together
that's right ladies we're gonna bring
you progress we're gonna liberate you
women by forcing you to bunk up with big
gigantic Bubba over there when you're in
prison what could go wrong isn't that
great isn't that progress reminds me of
a line from Lucille Ball Lucille Ball
was asked during an interview I think
maybe with Dick Cavett many decades ago
what she thought about women's lib and
she said I think I'm liberated enough I
think I could use a little less
Liberation I don't think women's lib has
made women very very happy and you can
see this in study after study take
studies of happiness with a grain of
salt but all of them seem to show that
women have become much less happy since
women's lib came about both relative to
men and in absolute terms
the era would do all sorts of other
things would it effectively abolish
women's bathrooms the transgender
activists are trying to do that already
would effectively ban women's sports
would would end women's schools and all
the special rights and spaces that women
have specifically for themselves right
now how did this thing come about
well the era actually was not first
proposed in the 70s it became to
prominence in the 70s the era that was
first proposed in 1923. this was the
first version of it written by Alice
Paul and Crystal Eastman and it was
introduced into Congress didn't get very
far
then there's another move to revive in
the 1970s Congress set a ratification
deadline of March 22nd 1979. that by
1977 the era had received 35 of the
necessary 38 states to ratify it so the
feminists realized it wasn't going to
work to get this thing through Congress
people didn't want it but if they if
they tried to surreptitiously go through
all of the different states and get it
ratified they might over time push this
thing through so they were so close in
1977 at 35 out of 38 States and then
Along Came not some man some patriarchal
misogynistic man to put those women in
their place no Along Came
a little lady by the name of Phyllis
Schlafly a conservative woman one of the
most important conservative leaders in
America certainly of the 20th century
really I would say ever
she was a religious mother of six I
believe and she rallied women around
America not the women that the feminists
like not the crazy hair burning their
bras woman needs a man like a fish needs
a bicycle kind of feminist ladies
but normal regular women who love their
husbands who love their sons who love
their home life who love their special
privileges and places and rights and
spaces in society rallied those women
around America and said no we don't want
this progress that would destroy our
role in society
that point five State legislatures Idaho
Kentucky Nebraska Tennessee South Dakota
voted to revoke their era ratifications
so they'd already ratified it they said
nope we don't want this thing anymore
the first four rescinded their
ratification before the original 1979
deadline South Dakota did so by voting
to Sunset the ratification as of the
original deadline so the original
deadline hits okay no more era because
they couldn't get it through in 1978 the
libs kept it up Congress passed by
simple majorities in each house and and
Jimmy Carter signed as president a joint
resolution to extend the deadline which
is legally a little bit dubious but they
said okay we couldn't get the damn thing
through well all right let's push it a
few more years 1982 and then guess what
happened in those three years no
additional State legislatures ratified
the era because nobody wants it because
it's insane
then in 2020 just three years ago
Virginia's General Assembly passed a
ratification resolution for the era
which then claimed to bring that number
up to 38. but of course it did not there
are so many reasons that obviously
didn't work they've blown through
deadline after deadline in order to
claim that they had 38 States they would
have to ignore the fact that five State
legislatures withdrew their ratification
it's just nonsense they keep but this is
what the libs do they just doggedly
pursue their agenda even if the people
hate it even if it's not particularly
legal or constitutional they just
they're they're like a dog with a bone
they don't let go that's why they
generally win and the culture War stuff
the reason I mention this now is to be
on the alert because they're they're
going to keep pushing for this and we
need to shoot it down it would be
terrible for women to be terrible for
society but also to point out
that there's a line that some
conservatives have used in recent years
that it's not true they'll say look we
hate
second wave feminism that's the bra
burners of the 70s that second wave
feminism was bad
the Third Way of feminism which was I
don't know it was like the 90s 2000s
that was also bad and now I think we're
in the fourth wave I don't know or if
the 50th wave whatever wave we're in
that's also bad but this is what they
would say they'll say the first wave
feminists they were really good
those first wave feminists back in the
20s they were the good ones and it's not
true they're all the same people they're
all the same feminism is just bad okay
it's bad because it posits and this is
the same issue that we see with
transgenderism
deposits a false anthropology
it suggests that there is no meaningful
difference between men and women
the traditional way of viewing men and
women is that men and women are
different Men Are from Mars Women Are
from Venus men and women go together
you're never going to have a war between
the Sexes because everybody's Sleeping
with the Enemy oh man and we will never
understand each other but that's what
adds spice to life and we love that and
that's why men and women are coupled
with one another human beings or a
coupling species and we come together
and by golly we can procreate isn't that
so amazing it's only through the union
of a man and a woman that we can
actually partake of God's creation
because what we what we can do without
one another is we can you know I can
produce this show and though I need a
whole Army of people to actually you
know make the show happen but we can all
we can all do that we can make a work of
art we can write a poem we can bake a
pie but in order to partake of actual
creation not just putting stuff together
and building it but actually creating
new life
you need men and women together that's
the old way of viewing things the modern
view the feminist views that men and
women don't need each other they're
they're basically the same anyway it
gets a little confusing because the
feminists would argue that men and women
certainly have the same brains and their
their physical differences are just
superficial they only run Skin Deep
whereas the transgenderists now claim
that men and women have totally
different brains which is how men who
think they're women they actually
allegedly have the brain of a woman or
something like that which irritates many
of the feminists because the feminists
say who the hell are you to tell me that
my brain isn't the same as a man's brain
and so they'll try to Duke it out but
it's it all derives from the same false
anthropology yes the second way
feminists were bad they're all bad
though because it's all wrong it's
either true or false it happens to be
false and we should oppose this stuff
this is going to be the topic of my
speech in Buffalo I'm giving a speech
with Young Americans Foundation up at
the University of Buffalo on Thursday
very very excited for that the topic
that I've been requested to speak on is
feminism and you know since I Am The
Love Guru here at the daily wire Dr
romance I I have I have many thoughts on
this topic and and thoughts on the topic
of sex and gender in politics more
broadly because where conservatives are
always just fighting on the terms of the
left so now we're fighting over whether
or not we should trans the
eight-year-olds if not the nine-year-old
so we're fighting over whether we should
abolish women's sports we've gotta we've
got to go a little bit deeper we've got
to take on
the feminists
speaking of New York
mayor Eric Adams he's not a very good
mayor he's a big lib New York City is
not doing very well under his leadership
but he's also not the worst mayor we've
ever had especially coming after Bill de
Blasio you know I'm a New Yorker by
upbringing and so I care still a lot
it's very sad to see poor old Gotham
descend into crime in Mayhem and Eric
Adams said something the other day where
I felt I had to give him credit where
credits do he said that
when God and prayer and the Bible left
schools that's when the guns came into
schools
so he's trying to make a little knock at
guns in the Second Amendment but okay
I'm willing to overlook that because
he's defending
God in schools that's a very
conservative position very out of step
with the rest of his party so mayor
Adams went on CNN and the CNN lady
grilled him over this she was Furious
she said how dare are you suggesting
that there is no firm separation of
church and state here's mayor Adams's
answer
you also said you implement policies
with a quote god-like approach and said
quote when we took prayers out of
schools gum guns came into schools you
know that those comments alarmed some
people even some religiously related
religious leaders rather who were in the
room a rabbi who was there called it
dangerous well listen let's be clear on
something uh the last words I said after
I was sworn in is so help me God on our
dollar bill we have in God we trust
every president touched a religious book
when they were sworn in uh except for
three
faith is who I am and anyone who takes
those words are stating that I'm going
to try to compel people to follow my
religion no I'm a I'm a Child of God I
believe that Holy I'm going to follow
the law I'm not going to compel people
who believe in whatever faith it could
be of you in the synagogue a Baptist
Church a Buddhist temple I'm in all of
them and that's what was in my my
service just to be clear do you
fundamentally believe in the separation
of church and state from a governing
standpoint no what I believe is that you
cannot separate your faith
awesome
love that this guy this liberal Democrat
has more courage on this very important
issue than many if not most Republicans
in public life
do you not believe in a separation of
church and state very simply goes no
no I don't
good that puts him on the same side as
the founding fathers every American
statesman until the 60s and 70s 1960s
and 70s and every great leader and
Statesman throughout all of history
since the dawn of time
of course not and his reasoning is quite
right he says
faith
is everything to me it informs
everything I do he says I'm not going to
force people to join my denomination or
particular religious View
I'm all for Toleration but
you can't separate me from my faith
and if you can't separate me from my
faith and you can't separate my face my
faith from government because I am the
person in office right now of course all
politics all human conflict ultimately
is theological
it has to be that's always inevitable
the
I've mentioned the writer Matthew
petruzik's excellent way of thinking
about this
politics is on top of morality is on top
of epistemology is on top of
anthropology is on top of ontology is on
top of theology
alter without getting into every
category ultimately
you've got to get down to the question
of what is everything
what
is everything that is resting upon
and that is a theological question
you can't you can't pass a law about
taxes or parking tickets without getting
down to some theological premises
you can't do it it's not possible so
he's he's just being honest about that
and the people who say no we're gonna
have a separation of church and state
no no we don't I don't let my religious
views affect my politics that's what
John F Kennedy said when he was running
for president and he was afraid that by
being Catholic he would lose they said
oh I'm listening yeah I'm very Catholic
but I would never let my Catholic faith
affect anything I do okay so practically
speaking you're not all that Gap like
okay fine Adams is saying no of course
we all do that
and he does it too I love it great great
on him I hope I have Republican leaders
follow this mostly failed liberal mayor
of New York at least on this question
say okay yeah absolutely
and that allows you to be tolerant when
you know what you stand for and you're
being very clear and very open you can
be tolerant of minority religious views
he says I'm not going to go after the
Hindus or whatever and or Buddhists and
try to convert them to my way of
thinking
he's going to tolerate it but
you can only tolerate these sort of
minority views if you have a broadly
established
set of norms and standards that derive
from the that derive from faith and the
majority faith in the country
people who are not very tolerant I've
learned or some of the radical
transgender activists you're gonna be
shocked to hear that there's a story
that came out I'm afraid I might have
something to do with this
uh called the
trans day of vengeance
when I when I saw that headline I
realized they
are now taking my advice from some years
ago I gave a speech on leftism through
the lens of the seven deadly sins I said
why is it the lib celebrate pride pride
is the queen of all vices and Drew
claven pointed out that now it's also
the vice of all queens I said why would
you if you want from just a PR
standpoint to promote your sexual group
why would you base it on Pride the
deadliest of the seven deadly sins and I
said why pride in particular if you're
going to make it based on a sin why not
a gay gluttony weak or why not gay wrath
week or and well so now we're getting it
essentially the trans day of Wrath
to stop the alleged transgender genocide
that nobody knew was happening
this is the trans radical activist
Network
said on Twitter the time is now enough
is enough
we want more visibility and so they're
calling for vengeance vengeances
pretty violent
language pretty violent concept I view
the Vengeance as as belonging to the
Lord I don't think that it's up to me to
take Vengeance on people so even if I uh
am inclined to anger and I'm really
upset with somebody and I want revenge I
do my level best to put that away kiss
it up give that to God because revenge
is the Lord's
which which brought me back to this
whole crazy nontroversy about the libs
accusing me of genocide
because one of the reasons it's so
laughable other than it had no basis in
anything I've ever said it is
I'm Christian
that's the foundation of my belief a
Catholic specifically
I
think that I will be answerable for all
the things that I have done in my life
and I know that I sin a lot which is why
I uh ask Christ's forgiveness I confess
my sins I seek Absolution I hope that my
redeemer and I have good good reason to
Hope but that my redeemer will save me
because I can't save myself
even when I'm writing this show and half
of this show is about poking fun at all
these insane ideas that the libs have I
try to make sure that I don't fall into
the sin of detraction
where I am intentionally revealing
secret sins of other people or using it
really cruel and harsh language about
people and even that I try in in the way
that I conduct my life and we all fail
constantly and I certainly Chief among
them I
I'm really really careful because I
think that I'm going to be answerable
for my words and my actions someday
these people do not think that
which is why these people tend to be
a little more
a little less morally constrained in the
way they deal with themselves and other
people
this is why the political violence in
recent years has come not exclusively
but
largely from the left this is why BLM
burned the country down for months this
is why antifa has attacked so many
people torched places they're always
encouraging violence this is why you've
now got these these people who obviously
are not playing with a full deck just
generally now calling for vengeance and
obviously much more radical kind of
language
who are they answerable to this is why
this question that the CNN lady asked to
Eric Adams is is so crazy the libs fear
that if politicians believe in God
that's going to cause them to do all
manner of terrible things
if you think
that
the
God-fearing politicians are bad
just wait until you see the politicians
who don't fear God
this is this is a way it's a kind of
obscured in the history now but we all
make fun of Divine Right monarchies this
sort of absurd idea and it's that we
view Divine Right monarchs as being
absolute tyrants wielding but that isn't
true the idea of Divine Right monarchy
is actually that there is a limit on the
power of the Monarch because the Monarch
is answerable to God who is a lot more
important and powerful than a politician
who's answerable only to the people or
answerable only to a small group say in
an oligarchy this is the meaning of John
Adams's famous statement the
Constitution is built for a moral and
religious people that's the constraint
when you take that constraint away in
the name of the separation of church and
state or the enlightened views of
secularism and when you take that away
you're going to lose the grace you're
going to lose the restraints you're
going to lose the kiss it up for
vengeance as the Lords and you're going
to get a lot of Wrath
and gluttony and pride and lust and all
the rest of it you're going to get a
country burning to the ground as we have
seen in recent years
that's our that's our Brave New World
before maybe I'll just tease this story
because this story is really really wild
on the Brave New World
you may have heard the world economic
Forum say that in the future you will
own nothing and be happy
this sounds like something I have a
James Bond villain's mouth
but a lot of people wonder well how's
that going to happen you're not taking
my stuff you can come you show up here
you try to take my stuff threaten my
family you're going to catch a face full
of lead is what you're going to do
that's what a lot of people tell
themselves with that independent Spirit
of I'm going to keep my stuff
but the way that the Brave New World
great reset Vision will be put into
practice and is currently being put into
practice it's not that Jack booted thugs
necessarily are going to come to your
door and kick it in and and grab you
it's that even the products you buy are
going to be less and less yours Ford
Motor Company Ford Global Technologies
just filed a patent for a new system and
method to repossess a vehicle and the
way they're going to do it is they're
going to sell you the car you're going
to buy the car you're going to think you
own the car and then whenever the Ford
executive wants he's going to lock you
out of that car he could repossess that
car you won't have anything to say about
it we'll have to get into that a little
bit more tomorrow because I want to take
calls right now before that
back in 2021 during a five hour hearing
before Congress Mark Zuckerberg admitted
that he did not let his own children use
Facebook that should be enough to make
you think twice about letting your kids
use any social media especially Tick
Tock there's a new book out published by
DW books written by Bethany Mandel and
Carol Markowitz that drives that point
home it's called stolen youth how
radicals are erasing innocence and
indoctrinating a generation when I read
this passage I wanted to delete every
social media app that I have and throw
my phone away I already have that
inclination generally and this passage
really underscored it listen to this
quote Tick Tock was the center of a 2021
Wall Street Journal investigation which
uncovered how the app targets users with
content revolving around sex drugs
eating disorders and more calling it an
addiction machine investigators created
31 accounts registered to young teens
and turned them loose to browse tick
tocks for you feed the highly
personalized never-ending feed curated
by the algorithm the article explained
quote an analysis of the videos served
to these accounts found that through its
powerful algorithms Tick Tock can
quickly Drive miners among the biggest
users of the app into endless spools of
content about sex and drugs Tick Tock
served One account registered as a 13
year old at least 569 videos about drug
use references to cocaine and meth
addiction and promotional videos for
online sales of drug products and
paraphernalia hundreds of similar videos
appeared in the feeds of the journal's
other minor accounts remember
this is not an accident this is by
Design radicals want your children sick
and corrupted good news is
you can fight back right now you can
figure out how to fight back stolen
youth how radicals are erasing innocence
and indoctrinating a generation comes
out today order your copy on Amazon or
wherever you get your books now
and now
I will have the Supreme privilege of
speaking to you on the line taking your
calls who do we have let me peruse
who we have here
okay
let's turn to my home state
let's turn to Charles in New York
Charles you're on the line
Michael thank you very much for taking
my call um I said a quick question I've
been following the Hershey's controversy
it disgusts me as much as anyone uh but
I wonder if the solution to fight back
against what these corporations are
doing is to you know quite honestly is
it to buy Jeremy's chocolate or is it to
invest that you know 25 bucks six bucks
a chocolate bar in a gym membership in a
home Garden in locally grown organic
produce I don't understand what uh is
accomplished by you know substituting
one chocolate bar for another take that
25 bucks instead of buying chocolate
give it to your local Parish I'm just
curious what your thoughts are on why
it's important to buy Jeremy's chocolate
instead of taking you know that money
again and and rather than filling our
bodies with sugar you know doing
something maybe a bit more uh productive
with it sure that's a really good
question if you don't like chocolate and
you you want to get off chocolate that's
totally fine I mean especially if you
know you're trying to lose weight or
something like that yeah that that's
totally fine but my question for you is
do you like chocolate
I do like chocolate but I I would um uh
I again I I just don't know if that's
you know the the right direction to go
but my question then is if you like I
like chocolate I eat chocolate now I
don't need a ton okay I gotta keep my
spelled figure I gotta fit into wardrobe
for the show but if you are going to eat
chocolate
the question is are you gonna buy
Hershey's chocolate Hershey's which
hates you and wants to trans the culture
and is doing very bad things with your
money or would you rather buy Jeremy's
chocolate even if it's what you know six
bucks a bar whatever amount of money
you're going to spend on chocolate would
you rather spend that money there I'm
not saying you have to buy Jeremy's
chocolate I I think it's very funny and
I really got a kick out of the whole
thing I fully intend to get myself some
Jeremy's chocolate but no it's not it's
not saying that the way to fight the
culture war is that we all need to buy a
lot of chocolate the way to fight the
culture war is to stop buying products
from the companies that hate you and
purchase those same products that you
would already buy from from companies
that like you instead and that are not
trying to trans the kids and they're
actually using that money to try to
fight back against the web Corporation
so I don't I don't think it's an either
or if you want to go to the gym donate
money to charity donate to your church I
think that's all great stuff and well
forget the gym but at least donating to
charity into your church is probably a
higher priority than getting yourself
chocolate the point of Jeremy's
chocolates and razors and all the rest
of it is not that you should put all
your money into that the point is that
if you are going to buy those products
already consumers ought to have an
option and we shouldn't be forced into
this Monopoly or oligopoly to give all
of our money to companies that hate us
and that use that money use our money to
screw up our culture that's the whole
point then if you want to go to the gym
I encourage you to work out enough for
the two of us because I certainly don't
intend to go to the gym and I will then
perhaps eat double the chocolate very
good question Charles let's turn now
to Gideon in Canada America's Top Hat
Gideon how about your appearance on this
show eh
thanks a lot for taking the call uh I
just want to Echo a point uh made by
John Doyle actually somebody I think
that you should have on the show uh I
met John Doyle a few times I like him
oh he's wonderful yes uh he said that
when transgender people uh see calls to
eliminate transgender ideology from
society they construe it as genocidal as
of course I'm sure you've had plenty of
experience with at this point
um but when people begin calling for the
elimination of quote unquote whiteness
so call out the obvious is something
that even most conservatives won't
actually do so I don't know like how
else are we supposed to construe that
well of course well there's no question
about that that the The Establishment in
the media and the government and all of
it just hates white people
and hates men too so of course that's
the case you're allowed to say any
terrible stuff about men that you want
we have to abolish toxic masculinity and
of course that's never interpreted as a
genocide or we need to abolish whiteness
or eradicate whiteness no that is either
not interpreted as calling for genocide
or is uh celebrated is calling for
genocide but even you have people like
Oprah Oprah famously was was caught on
camera giving an answer to how we deal
with all these conservative people and
she said we just have to wait for them
to die so that was a pretty direct call
toward maybe she didn't want to hasten
their death but she wasn't upset that
they would die at some point anyway yeah
there's no question about that they're
just slightly different issues I think
you can as we talk about a lie you can
talk about how the culture is openly
antagonistic toward white people and and
men and people who have ordinary sexual
uh practices and desires and Christians
and all the rest of it you can talk
about that but it's I think it's also
worth pointing out that on this
particular issue with uh the Liberals
accusing me of genocide for suggesting
that we ought not to we
ought not to indulge the transgender
false anthropology uh you know that one
is a little bit different uh in that
transgender people is not a real
ontological category that it's a
euphemism to describe deeply confused
men and women who ought to have
psychological and spiritual help and so
I think we just need to be very precise
in our language and focus on that battle
when we're dealing with that battle and
focus on the other ones as well I don't
know that they're totally connected you
could make a rhetorical point that that
you know wins a point or two by pointing
out the left Wing's hypocrisy I just
don't think pointing out leftist
hypocrisy really matters to quote Adrian
vermeul the Harvard law professor
they're not exactly Hypocrites on the
left they're they just have a hierarchy
they just say some people are better
than other people and some people should
get special privileges and others should
be punished so in a way that's kind of
honest it's not hypocritical they just
have they have their own caste system
and set of values and and uh you know
you and I probably wouldn't wouldn't
fall very high up in that so a little
bit separate issues but both both very
important okay let's let's try to get to
at least one more before
before we turn to the member block with
the creme de La Creme in a circle Brady
in San Marcos Texas hello Brady how can
I help you
hey Michael um wife when I uh my wife
and I are big fans of the show uh your
first book left us without words and
your last book had a speechless uh so my
question is this my wife and I converted
to Christianity a little over a year and
a half ago and we largely retain our
secular friend group from before we were
saved uh you've talked a lot about
having secular friends gay friends
liberal friends and so on
um I know that as Christians we have a
calling to witness and to evangelize to
others but Proverbs also tells us that
his iron sharpens iron one man sharpens
another so at what point do you think
having too many secular friends having
too many friends who oppose your values
becomes a problem and what would be some
tips for remaining firm in the faith
without coming across as judgmental or
you know turning your secular friends
off from Christianity entirely thanks
great question I I would not recommend
that you cut your friends off you know
sometimes sometimes people say uh now
I've converted and so I'm not talking to
these people anymore if some of your
friends are occasions of sin if they
lead you into behaviors that are sinful
and that compromise your faith then
probably you should cut them off but if
that's not the case if you just have
differing viewpoints I wouldn't cut them
off but I I would just predict and
observe
of people grow together or they grow
apart
and it doesn't need to be some big
terrible breakup but
I think you might find as you deepen in
your faith you will naturally be
spending more time
with people who view things a little
more similarly to the way that you view
things
and you'll spend a little less time with
some of those other friends and
that's natural and people change and the
real with the real enduring friendships
your friends views might change as well
and if they don't
if you don't grow together then very
likely you will grow apart and that's
that's just the way friendship works
okay it is now time to get to the member
block
we will be today examining a really
important trend on Tick Tock that would
be the trend of Trad wives
traditional wives I'm pleased to be
married to such such a wife and
specifically the trend of left Wingers
disparaging Trad wives
they hate them because they hate them I
suspect the rest of the show continues
now you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles Canada w-l-e-s
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign